welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka definition in this video we're going
to be breaking down our big fan theories
on both black noir and stormfront
the pair are probably the most
mysterious characters in the comic book
caper
and throughout this video we're gonna be
discussing who we think they really are
and how it ties in with the source
material there's gonna be heavy spoilers
here for the first five episodes of
season two
so if you aren't caught up then you
better make like that super terrorist
from the first episode
and head off hey great great
great videos here now with that other
way thank you for clicking this
let's get into our fan theories okay so
firstly i want to talk about black noir
and who i think he really is there's
been a lot of speculation over his
identity since the start
and i myself have gone back and forth
over whether the series would follow the
comics or not
in the original work it was revealed
that black noir was actually a clone of
homelander that was put in place by vort
to take the character down in case he
ever ended up going rogue
that was a big twist in the comics and
the show has even teased it coming true
with the characters standing in the same
pose
for a lot of the marketing material
however the twist is so well known at
this point that i think it's just gonna
get spoiled by someone
preferably myself the spoiler man
so what can the show do to keep things
in line with the comics
but also leave enough there to surprise
people well personally
i think that the latest entry might have
just given us a big clue about who it
could actually be
now i did originally think that noir
might be a clone of billy butcher
in the comics in show we learned that
the character worked with the cia in the
past
and this involved him being selected for
missions in which he would spy on the
supes and even take them down at certain
points
i initially thought that vault could
have become aware of this and then
cloned the character
so that if it came down to it they could
use the hate which was already instilled
in him
to take down homelander billy would also
be blindsided by this reveal
and for vul it would be a win-win
situation in which they could take down
homeland if needs be
but also shocked the boys enough to the
point that noah would get an opening to
take them out if ever it came down to it
however i think the fifth episode might
have already teased who the character
could be
and that is lenny aka billy's brother
now in the show we find out very little
about him and in the comics
it's about the same bar a couple of
lines of text
there's little that we learn about him
and i think that this show has planted
the idea that he and huey are very
similar for a specific reason
we learned that lenny died and because
of this huey has become somewhat of a
surrogate brother to billy who took him
under his wing
and views him as a canary i'm i'm here
all week
but what if lenny didn't actually die
and instead
vo took him captive and gave him
compound v
turning him into the mindless killer
that's black noir now in the comics and
show
as demonstrated by the latest episode
noir is pretty much a drone that's used
by edgar to do his dirty work
whether this is him covering up the
compound v getting out in syria
or tracking down butcher the villain is
relentless in all that he does
however there's one key scene in which
we actually see some of his personality
come out
early on in the season there's a brief
moment in which we catch black noir
crying
this seems like it's because of compound
b getting out but what if it goes beyond
that
the newscaster can be heard talking
about the treatment of people by vote
and how this causes several issues what
if
this is actually the character's true
personality breaking through for a brief
second if lenny had been taken in by the
corporation and then brainwashed
there is still a possibility that he
could have had a small breakthrough
during this moment
before he was once more ordered to
become edgar's attack dog
we know from the brief flash of
lamplighter in episode 5
that there is a facility in which the
rogue suits are housed
and what if at this location lenny was
brainwashed and transformed into noir
now why this would be interesting on a
meta level is because
jack quaid could actually play the
character as we know that lenny and huey
are meant to resemble one another
when they finally unmask noir not only
would it completely catch billy off
guard
but it would also probably startle huey
too and i think this double twist would
be a brilliant way to keep things in
line with the source material
whilst also giving both characters that
you know that one
oh shh moment i can't say because of
youtube now they give a lot of focus to
huey
lenny and billy in the last episode and
to bring noir into it too
i think in retrospect would make the
family reunion and judy's home
get a lot more gravitas to it again this
is just a theory
but i think if it came true it would be
a really cool reveal
now as for stormfront this isn't so much
a theory as it's becoming more and more
obvious that she's going to be a close
adaptation of her counterpart in the
comic books
originally when ayakash first came onto
the scene i thought that a stormfront
was going to be a big departure from the
source material
however by episode 3 it was clear that
they were actually doing a bait and
switch
and that she is in fact the character
from the comics with a little gender
switch to keep the audience guessing
now in case you don't know in the source
material stormfront was actually created
during world war
ii bought was a german scientist and
under hitler's watchful eye he
experimented on jewish people in order
to create compound b
stormfront's mother was injected with
heavy doses of it and he's probably the
person that should be classed as the
first superhero
stormfront has such a legacy and we
learned that in the comics that
homelander was actually cloned from him
which yeah if they carry this over to
the show it's gonna make the the laser
bube
scene even weirder now hitler had the
characters serving as a super soldier in
world war ii
as part of his youth program however
hitler turned on him
and ordered that the character be
executed vault
angered that his greatest creation was
going to be sent to the scrap heap
decided to flee the country with the boy
and then he founded the corporation
and the rest is history i can actually
see a similar storyline being carried
across to the show
and with ayakash itself being jewish it
does tease that something happened with
her in the war
we already know from a timer's liberty
that the character does not age
and because of her views we can guess
that she was likely raised to be like
this
which further ties into the character's
origin story
stormfront likely keeps little reminders
of this and this could be seen in her
lightning earrings
these symbols look similar to the ones
used by the ss
or this could be a big reach like the
rest of the video
it's too late to take back the time
you've wasted now anyway so yeah
just keep watching now but seriously did
anyone buy that story about her mother i
mean seriously
we did see in episode 5 of season 2 that
she had a photograph of her
however if the character was alive in
the 70s and still looked in her late 20s
to early 30s
then surely something isn't right here
it's the first real clue that we've had
about the characters past beyond the
liberty reveal
and there are several ways that we can
take this either this is her mother and
our theory is wrong
in which case she was probably born in
the 50s was injected with compound v
about then too rose's liberty and then
was brushed to the side of the 70s after
her attack
the second option is that this is just a
pr stunt by vort
to make her origin story seem more
authentic they've done this before
several times and initially all of the
seven had complete origin stories
such as being from alien planets or
atlantis before the compound bee truth
was revealed
this is the one i'm leaning to at the
moment and it is possible that they
hooked her up with a new cover story
after liberty was kicked out of the
spotlight the third option is
that this is actually her daughter now
shout outs to cameron warren on my last
boys video for dropping this
but it kind of sparked me off into
thinking that it's a possibility
too stormfront would have to be close to
character in order to use her name as a
password
and it does seem like she's tied to her
in some way if she's not her mother as i
guessed
then it does make sense that she could
be the other end of the spectrum who
knows
stormfront might even be bort's child
herself and this is why the company was
so protective over her
we've seen with the deep that they don't
mind getting rid of someone when they do
bad
so the fact that they kept her around
means she must be pretty high up
vault could have experimented on his own
daughter in order to perfect the
compound
and this would also give him someone
that he could control
anyway that's all our fan theories for
the moment but obviously i'd love to
hear yours in the comments below
do you agree do you not or do you have
an even better one
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video yeah then make sure
you check out our full breakdown of
episode 5 which is going to be linked at
the end
we go over all the easter eggs in the
entry so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below the winner is going to be
chosen at random on the 30th of
september and the set will be shipped
out from then to ever gets the prize
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part if you want to support the
channel and get to see content like this
early then please consider clicking the
join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or a heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
to say